мене турбує чи є бажання заходу
продовжувати робити те що має бути
зроблено сильні слова від мого гостя
цього тижня колишнього заступника
головнокомандувача військами НАТО в
Європі Річарда ширифа у Європі серед
європейських країн все ще існує відчуття
що якимись чином ми можемо повернутися
до якогось статусу кво з Росією цього не
станеться тож що на його думку станеться
у центрі уваги деякі тривожні
перспективи і гучний Тривожний дзвінок
для Європи та Америки
Генерала Річарда ширев Ласкаво просимо
до конфліктзон щиро дякую приємно бути
тут з вами останніми тижнями Україна
досягла певних успіхів на полі бою вони
фактично повернули контроль над буровими
платформами в Чорному морі але мені
цікаво Чи можете ви окреслити нам
масштаб викликів з якими зараз
стикається Київ щоб досягти подальших
успіхів я думаю було б справді важко
переоцінити цей виклик я маю на увазі що
українці виступають проти добре
налагодженої російської оборони росіяни
встигли окопатися Вони знають про те як
окопуватися і окопалися мабуть за
правилами тож українці повинні
прорватися через цю дуже-дуже укріплену
смугу оборони вони повинні розмінувати
Мінні поля їм доводиться справлятися з
потужним артилерійським обстрілом вони
повинні прорватися а потім вони повинні
вирватися і вони змушені робити усе це
без належного прикриття з повітря без
переваги в повітрі чого б не погодилася
робити жодна армія НАТО і фактично те що
вони роблять це те чого не робила жодна
армія НАТО крапка Вони долають перешкоди
у дуже складних
умовах жодна інша армія НАТО за винятком
США не змогла б навіть впоратися з цим у
їхній нинішній формі чи не
так Я думаю що будь Яка армія НАТО яка
прагне вести бойові дії високої
інтенсивності буде готова взяти це на
себе Але не з такою малою кількістю часу
підготовки навчання нарощування
обладнання боєприпасів і виконання цього
під час операції Буря в пустелі в
1991 році коаліція прорвала оборонні
позиції Іраку але не зустріла опору тож
це було досить легко з часів Другої
світової війни в Європі цього ніхто не
робив
армії НАТО витратили роки на боротьбу з
повстанцями В таких місцях як Ірак який
ви згадали Афганістан Тож вони не звикли
захищатися від величезного вторгнення
але в Останні кілька місяців ви
наголошували і казали що вони повинні це
те що на вашу думку
станеться я думаю що якщо НАТО хоче
стримувати Росію в довгостроковій
перспективі НАТО має бути готовим до
найгіршого сценарію тобто бути готовим
до боротьби з Росією армії НАТО повинні
відкинути антиповстанське мислення і
відновити той дух і розуміння бойових
дій високої інтенсивності які були
основою армії НАТО під час холодної
війни Це було дуже давно і тому Нове
покоління має знайти способи зробити
це останнім часом НАТО не виглядало
швидким чи не так ми бачили як армії
членів НАТО провели кілька днів навчань
у Латвії де стало зрозумілим що не весь
особовий склад НАТО говорить однією
мовою з однаковим ступенем знання і це
вже не кажучи про пригоди з технікою три
з 24х британських військових машин
зламалися на автомагістралі це не вражає
чи не
так я залишаюся прихильником НАТО Але у
випадку з НАТО Ви повинні визнати що це
займає час що це організація консенсусу
і вона має рухатися зі швидкістю
найповільнішого корабля в конвої це
стратегічний момент повертаючись до
тактичних моментів про які ви говорите
То для цього і потрібні вправи щоб
перевірити і виправити це зрозуміти де
щось іде не так і мати можливість це
виправити швидкість НАТО
багатонаціональні операції принаймні тут
але організації потрібно відточувати
свої здібності шляхом навчання якщо НАТО
може це зробити і справді прагне до
досконалості тоді організація може
розпочати розбудовувати необхідну
здатність
стримування але якщо вони не розвинуть
свою досконалість зараз коли Вони
збираються це зробити минуло понад 18
місяців найбільшої сухопутної війни в
Європі з часів Другої світової війни
хіба В наші дні справи не повинні йти
Трохи краще Ну я б хотів бачити що усе
йде краще з самого початку Ми повинні
визнати що ця війна почалася не в лютому
2022 року Вона почалася в березні 14
року коли Росія напала на Україну чи
можливо у лютому 2014 року коли вона
анексувала Крим і якби тоді НАТО
прокинулося і дійсно запровадило заходи
необхідні для розбудови свого
високоінтенсивного потенціалу то а ми
могли б бути не там де ми є і б Україна
могла б бути не там де є у будь-якому
випадку факт полягає в тому що ми там де
ми є Тому треба наполегливо працювати і
докладати зусиль тож я цілком з вами
дний Минулого року прем'єр-міністр
Естонії Кая калас попередила що згідно з
попередніми планами НАТО щодо захисту
країн Балтії її країна була б фактично
стерта з карти світу наступом Росії чи
численний штат планувальників НАТО за
всі роки холодної війни просто упустив
таку
ймовірність саме тому я написав свою
книгу війна з Росією висвітлюючи загрозу
для країн Балтії написано як Тривожний
дзвінок щоб змусити НАТО замислитися над
тим що вони будуть робити тому що Кая
калас була абсолютно права що якби
росіяни атакували Це дало б НАТО два
варіанти перший погодитися і прийняти це
другий- здійснити масове Вторгнення в
країни Балтії щоб відвоювати їх і тому
зараз це абсолютно Правильно хоч я і не
знайомий із плануванням але НАТО
впроваджує масштабні плани щодо захисту
території НАТО і це саме те що вони
повинні робити Але для того щоб втіли
плани в життя і потрібні засоби захисту
і це повертає нас дорзбудови можливостей
стримування НАТО а це означає
зосередження на конфлікті високої
інтенсивності та можливостях необхідних
для конфлікту високої
інтенсивності це також означає надавати
гроші для цього чи не так У вас є три
найбільші економіки в НАТО У вас є
Франція Німеччина та Італія які досі не
платять 2% ВВП на оборону то який сигнал
надсилає Кремлю їм
байдуже Я думаю це дає досить Поганий
сигнал давайте спочатку розглянемо
позитивні сторони Я маю на увазі
позитивні сторони таких країн Як Польща
яка абсолютно нарощує свій потенціал
поїдьте в країни Балтії Естонію Латвію
Литву так само я нещодавно був у Чехії
Чеська Республіка справді вкладає гроші
і нарощує свої можливості але ви
абсолютно праві країни як Німеччина
Італія Франція ще не починали витрачати
2% ВВП дійсно оборонний бюджет Німеччини
на 2023 рік нижчий ніж був на 2022
рік який сигнал це надсилає що це
говорить про так званий цайтвенде це так
званий момент великих змін коли
Німеччина збиралася гарантувати 2% ВВП
щорічно на оборону
ріші сунак сказав що Британія
витрачатиме
2-2,5% ВВП коли економіка дозволить Я
боюся що це недостатньо добре тому
західноєвропейським країнам відверто
кажучи потрібно
Прокинутися якби ви проаналізували війну
в Україні З усією суворою
матеріально-технічною військовою та
політичною невизначеністю наскільки б ви
хвилювалися ну япмі за своєю природою
але я також реаліст Я думаю що Україна
досягне своїх військових цілей Україна
не збирається припиняти боротьбу
рішучість України абсолютно надзвичайна
українці знають що якщо вони перестануть
воювати то Україна перестане існувати як
держава Тож вони продовжують воювати
Доки не переможуть Росію разом із
заходом чи без нього що Мене хвилює Так
це підтримка України заходом і США ми
наближаємося до року виборів
троє провідних кандидатів від
республіканської партії заявили що
припинять американську підтримку України
а рік виборів означає потенційну
нерішучість і застій Мене хвилює
здатність підтримки з боку
Британії Наприклад чи зможе Британія
продовжувати поглиблювати підтримку і
надавати боєприпаси та інші можливості
які потрібні Україні Мене хвилює
ухиляння від цього наприклад Німеччина
досі не визначилася чи відправляти
Таурус високоточно ракету великої
дальності яка має серйозні можливості і
це саме те що потрібно Україні щоб
доповнити хаймарс і британський шторм
Shadow Отже мене турбує чи є бажання
заходу продовжувати робити те що має
бути зроблено і тут є просте рівняння
якщо захід зробить те що потрібно
зробити то він буде у більшій безпеці
оскільки це означатиме що Україна зможе
швидко перемогти Росію якщо це триватиме
і триватиме захід і Європа у цілому
будуть у меншій безпеці та під
загрозою пане річарде Сьогодні ми мало
говоримо про честь у війнах але на вашу
думку чи чесна позиція заходу сказати
Україні добре ви боріться і помирайте за
наші цінності і ми дамо вам щось із того
що вам потрібно для цього Але ми не
будемо сильно ризикувати засмутити
вашого ворога щоб він не обернувся проти
нас це
гідно Я думаю що було б дуже важко
назвати це гідним я наприклад шкодую про
те що якимсь чином захід НАТО повинні
наполягати на тому щоб Україна вела
війну яка відповідає тому як це робила б
НАТО моя точка зору проста дайте
українцям засоби для виконання цієї
роботи і нехай вони займаються нею
звісно надайте підтримку з точки зору
розвідки Кібер та радіоелектронної
боротьби але не намагайтеся вгадувати і
передбачати дії українських генералів
Вони знають що працює вони воюють з
росіянами вже понад 18 місяців і вони
переграли росіян вони показали що вони
кращі але чого їм все ще бракує Так це
реальних можливостей і так само як ви
сказали щодо обмеження часу для України
абсолютно правильно щоб Україна могла
захищатися і здійснювати це невід'ємне
право на самозахист і якщо це означає
вдарити по Росії то нехай буде так боюся
що це так би мовити самостримування
заходу призвело лише до продовження
війни якби в України були засоби щоб
реально продовжити визволення Херсона в
листопаді минулого року все могло б бути
інакше насправді вони не мали
можливостей тому що Захід не дав їм того
що їм справді було потрібно вчасно і це
дозволило росіянам відновити свою лінію
фронту а соровікін почав будувати так
звану лінію оборони соровікіна що значно
ускладнює роботу українця Отже На війні
є просте рівняння Якщо ти маєш вплив
якщо ти концентруєш зусилля і робиш то
ти зможеш досягти своїх цілей якщо ти
займаєшся дриблінгом ухиляєшся то ти
значно погіршиш ситуацію тому що це може
зайняти Набагато набагато більше
часу а щодо використання Україною
касетних боєприпасів У вас немає
сумнівів з цього приводу 100 країн
оголосили касетні боєприпаси поза
законом касетні боєприпаси - це мерзений
аспект війни Звичайно вони є я
категорично засуджує використання
касетних боєприпасів але якщо Україні
вони потрібні для розчищення російських
траншейних систем на території України
то це зовсім інше ставлення це справа
українців але те що Україні потрібно так
це високоточний потенціал великої
дальності щоб вони могли націлитися на
російські матеріально-технічні об'єкти
штаб квартири тощо і дуже ускладнити
процес
росіянам генерале наскільки
збалансованою ця війна на вашу думку
наскільки погано все могло скластися для
України які можливі переломні моменти за
якими Україні потрібно
стежити що ж Україна має продовжувати
захищатися росіяни продовжуватимуть
проводити наступальні операції там де
бачать можливості оскільки вони справді
організовують певну форму наступу в
північній частині Луганщини здається але
без ефективного
результату тому Україна має продовжувати
захищати себе захищати свій центр
тяжіння своє джерело сили і джерелом
сили є народ його воля та рішучість нато
також має захистити своє джерело сили
Яким є згуртованість
Альянсу думаю Україна переможе я вважаю
що Україна зараз перемагає але на мій
погляд вона досягне остаточної Перемоги
лише тоді коли прорве російську оборону
і поставить під загрозу Крим та шляхи
постачання до Криму унеможливлюючи
росіян від того щоб вони утримувалися
там і це вимагатиме значно більших
зусиль і давайте також будемо чіткі це
не закінчиться одним наступом Я вважаю
що ми маємо бути готові підтримати
українців у серії контрнаступів усі вони
вимагатимуть такого ж рівня підготовки
обладнання боєприпасів як і для початку
першого наступу тож це може тривати
певний час Отже заходу НАТО потрібне
стратегічне терпіння щоб продовжувати
підтримувати Україну до кінця
гри ви висловлювали ймовірність Здається
це було в травневій статті що якщо Захід
не надасть усе обладнання Яке зараз
потрібне Україні перемога може бути
неможливою і військам НАТО можливо
доведеться безпосередньо втрутитися щоб
гарантувати перемогу Києва Як ви думаєте
це реальна можливість це те про що НАТО
коли-небудь серйозно думатиме на на То
ніколи серйозно не розглядало до 2014
року чи навіть після 2014 року
вторгнення Росії в Україну НАТО ніколи
всерйоз не замислювалося про загрозу для
країн Балтії ніколи не можна говорити
ніколи але це те для чого НАТО було
створене для
захисту якби НАТО справді Серйозно
думало що Росія вторгнеться в Україну то
я думаю ви побачили б зовсім інший
підхід стримування ще на саміті НАТО у
кардіфі у 2014 році на
тому ніколи нічого не варто виключати чи
доведеться НАТО втручатися Я сподіваюся
що ні але якщо альтернативою є
десятиліття глухого кута десятиліття
величезних втрат запущена болячка у
Східній Європі Хто знає можливо авіації
НАТО доведеться залучитися щоб похитнути
баланс тому що така безвихідна ситуація
у Східній Європі вздовж кордонів України
буде загрозою європейській
безпеці
якщо врешті-решт європейська безпека
буде під загрозою безпека НАТО буде під
загрозою НАТО можливо доведеться вжити
заходів для підтримки України Але спосіб
уникнути цього спосіб уникнути участі
НАТО - це подвоїти зараз І наступного
року те що потрібно Україні для
досягнення
Перемоги Як ви думаєте Як це може
відбуватися чи вважаєте ви що НАТО
коли-небудь досягне консенсусу щодо
плану введення та безпосередньої
допомоги українським силам маючи таких
членів як Угорщина Австрія Словаччина
Туреччина Усі вони володіють вето Як ви
думаєте чи НАТО колись діятиме спільно
для
цього звичайно Австрія не є членом НАТО
але ваша думка абсолютно справедлива що
звичайно за таких обставин консенсусу
було б неймовірно важко досягти Але як я
вже говорив раніше НАТО рухається зі
швидкістю найповільні корабля в конвої і
якщо загроза є обставини є а їх явно
немає на даний момент Та хто зна через
10 років усе може змінитися і якщо буде
потрібно НАТО туди
дійде У деяких своїх інтерв'ю ви
говорили про війну яка триватиме 2-три
роки немає швидких рішень чи є загроза
що за такий тривалий час війна Майже
нормалізується вона зникає заголовків
людям стає нудно вони втрачають бойовий
дух кількість грошей зменшується інші
пріоритети починають домінувати чи є
така можливість у цьому випадку Як ви
думаєте безумовно тіме і саме це Мене
хвилює захід втрачає інтерес захід
втрачає імпульс захід втрачає фокус
армії НАТО сили оборони НАТО не
будуються щоб протистояти загрозі
безсумнівно Мене хвилює те як я вже
сказав раніше що наступного року в
Америці будуть
вибори Америка продовжуватиме надавати
такі величезні можливості І це те за чим
ми маємо спостерігати і я повернуся до
моєї Думки як переконатися що Україна
швидко досягає своїх перемог це подвоїти
те що їй потрібно зараз щоб уникнути
цього довготривалого глухого
кута якою на вашу думку Європа вийде з
цієї війни вона вже не буде такою як до
цього ніщо вже не буде таким як було
після цієї війни Війна змінює все змінює
доктрину змінює все наше уявлення про
безпеку в Європі чи не
так Я думаю що в Європі серед
європейських країн все ще існує відчуття
що якимсь чином ми можемо повернутися до
якогось статусу кво з Росією стану який
існував до війни цього не станеться
припустиімо що Україна досягне своїх
військових цілей припустімо що зброя
замовкає Росія вивішують білий прапор
або настає перемир'я чи щось таке і
українці зможуть звільнити стільки своєї
країни скільки ми їм дозволимо настає
безпека яку Вони шукають це не зупинить
Росію і їхні
бажання Це не зупинить Росію і їхні
бажання який би лідер не був у Кремлі
Росія продовжуватиме прагнути усунути
Україну з карти світу у російській ДНК
закладено що Україна не може існувати як
держава не існує окремої нації чи
української
культури а це означає що Україна має
стати частиною НАТО це означає що для
того щоб захистити НАТО захистити Європу
захистити Альянс захистити Україну НАТО
має створити смугу стримування навколо
Східної Європи включаючи Україну Молдову
Грузію Можливо навіть колись Білорусь
для захисту від
Росії
тому що ми бачимо занепад Російської
імперії і це відбуватиметься протягом
десятиліть це не закінчиться швидко Вже
ваші та мої онуки зіткнуться з цим
викликом тому єдиний спосіб
довгостроково підтримувати мир у Європі
- це ефективне стримування НАТО і Це
змінить економічну фінансову динаміку та
те як Європа веде свій бізнес це моє
бачення того як все
відбуватиметься пане річардеширев на
жаль у на закінчився час дуже дякую за
те що ви були на конфліктзон Дякую що
[музика]
покликали